نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد ذكرت صحيفه
واشنطن في افتتاحيتها الرئيس هو بالفعل
اكبر رئيس فنان خدم الولايات المتحده على
الاطلاق وهو الان اكبر من الرئيس السابق
رونالدو بعامين في اليوم الاخير لولايته
الثانيه واذا رشح نفسه مجددا وفاس فسيبلغ
82 عاما عندما يحلف اليمين الدستوريه
استعداد لتولي مهام منصبه وسيكون اقرب الى
ال90 بحلول نهايه ولايته واستشهدت الصحيفه
بعدت مواقفها وصفاتها بالسقطات الذهنيه مر
بها الرئيس بارد من نسيان اسم وزير الدفاع
بعد اسابيع فقط من توله منصبه الى موقف
اخير خلال حملته الانتخابيه عندما تحدث
وهو قال ان التضخمها مشكله عالميه في
الوقت الراهن بسبب الحرب المشتعله في
العراق عوضا عن قوله اوكرانيا واختتمت
صحيفه افتتاحيتها بالقول انها ليست من
ابرز تشجيعيه سياسه الحزبه الديمقراطيه
لكننا نرفض الظن ان بيضا هو افضل مرشح
يمكن للحزب ان يتقدم به الانتخابات 24
وانه انا الاوان لي تنحي بيضا وان يفسح
المجال لشخص اخر يقود الحزب تتزمن هذه
المقاله مع دعوات داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
حسب رئيس النفسه تطالبه بعدمه رشح في
السباق الرئاسه القادمه
سبونج
بوب
الامريكي اهلا بكم الكريمين
معك يا استاذ احمد استاذ احمد ما جاء في
صحيفه مباشر
اعلاميه ولكن كذلك دعوات من داخل الحزب
خاصه
يعني اولا نريد ان نبدا بالسلام عليكم
استاذ ريم وعلى الاستاذ ايهاب ونبارك
لجميع المشاهدين بهذا الفوز التاريخي
للصقور الخضر
تاريخيه يعني اسعدتنا كلنا وحتى
النتيجه
بعد نهايه الفتره الاولى ليست جديده يعني
20 20 همم الرئيس الرئيس
توافقي وليس يعني ما هو رئيس الشعبي يحظى
بتاييد او كاريزما تجعل له قاعده
دائما كانت بعض الاجنحه التي توافقت حولك
على اساس انه هو الحل الافضل لهزيمه ترامب
في 2020 ترى انه يجب ان يغادر يعني بعد
نحقق الهدف الاساسي ولكن المشكله التي
وجهها هذا وجهها هذه
الحقه كل ما يجب عليه ان يحقق وليصبح يعني
هو المرشح الاقوى في الانتخابات القادمه
يعني وحققت تشريعيه تاريخيه
خرج من يعني من الانتخابات 22 بنصر كبير
جدا يعني اثبت من خلاله انه قادر على
توحيد الا يعني على توحيد
الديمقراطيين والمعتدلين امام موجه حمراء
كانت متوقعه يعني للذكر انه كانوا
الجمهوريه يتكلمون عن 60 و70 مقعد في مجلس
النواب الان لم يعني لم ينتهي العد بعد
ولكن الحد الاقصى الذي يمكن ان يصنعه عشر
مقاعد هذا هذا النصر لا يمكن ان يمر
بسهوله يعني راينا حتى الجناح اكثر همم
الجراحه التقدمه يعني اكثر تحفظا على
بايدن همم كانوا محتفلين
احمد هل ننسب هذا الانتصار لبيضا او ننسبه
لحضور تراب لان الباص كذلك يقول بان هذا
التجنب او هذا التجنيد او هذا هذه الاحاطه
همم لمحاوله همم اضعاف الجمهوريين كذلك
يعود لتكرار همم طرح سوره ما رايك يا
استاذ ايهاب هل توافق ضيفي او توافق بعض
المراقبين الذين قد يختلفون في بعض ايات
واهلا بالاستاذ احمد واسمحوا لي يعني
ابارك للمنتخب السعودي والتونسي انا ايضا
بدوري كان اداء يعني الاعظم في تاريخ كره
القدم العالميه للعربيه
طبعا ارحب بحضرتك بالاستاذ احمد واقول ان
يعني
ما ما هو امامنا الان في الواقع هو خساره
هذه الديمقراطيين لمجلس النواب
الديمقراطيين كانوا يسيطرون على مجلس
الشيوخ ومجلس النواب والبيت الابيض اليوم
يفقدون ال- همم المجلس النواب حتى ولو
كانت النسبه بسيطه فان هذه النسبه البسيطه
ستجعل الجمهوريين في واقع الامر لديهم نوع
من المناوره المطلوبه في هذا التوقيت
لتضييق الخناقه او لمضايقه البيت الابيض
والديمقراطين في محاوله فرد الكثير من
التشريعات او اقرار الكثير من القوانين
سواء متعلقه بامور داخليه او خارجيه
وسيكون على نفسها طبعا ملف اوكرانيا
خارجيا وداخليا عدد من الملفات المتعلقه
بالضرائب والتامين الصحي الى اخره نتفق او
نختلف يعني بغض النظر ولكن همم من وجهه
نظري جو بايدن عندما جاء الى البيت الابيض
هو لم ياتي بسبب شخصيته الكاريزميه كما
اتفق مع الاستاذ احمد في هذا الاطار ولم
ياتي بسبب الدعم القوي الذي قدمه له الشعب
الامريكي وانما جاء بسبب الدعايه الناجحه
التي استطاع من خلالها الديمقراطيون
التاكيد على همم عدم همم فتنه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في التعامل مع وبابا
كورونا كان هذا هو الاساس الذي همم ضرب
الجمهوريين والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في مقتل سياسي لان هو تحديدا تعامل هو
الجمهوريون المحافظون تحديدا ايضا بشكل
سلبي في معالجه وباء كرونه ما ادى بالجميع
او بمعظم الناخبين الى انتخاب ومع ذلك
يعني نقول ان جو بايدن او دونالد ترامب
والجمهوريين لم يخسروا بهذه النسبه
الكبيره حتى في انتخابات الرئاسه الماضيه
يعني دونالد ترامب تقريبا حصل على 69
مليون صوت من 150 مليون صوت انتخابي يعني
نقول في حدود 46% يستطيع ان يوفر هذه
الاربعه في المائه او الجمهوريون اذا ما
ارادوا ان ينتخبوا شخص اخر غير همم الرئيس
دونالد ترامب لي يمثلهم في الانتخابات
القادمه
من نقاط ايجابيه وكذلك من بعض النقائس
التي يمكن ان تشوب مسيره او شخصيه كذلك
بعدين هل تعتقد بانه سيرشح نفسه
للانتخابات الرئاسيات القادمه
ما عندي شكل الموضوع هذا يعني هو يعني لن
يتنازل عن ترشيح الحزب الا في حاله واحده
اما ان يكون يعني احنا نعرف ان صحه الرئيس
فايده يعني ليست ليست جيده تماما الرجل
كبير في السن وتعرض لمشاكل صحيه سابقا فهل
هناك عوارض صحيه لا نعرف عنها شيئا هل
هناك ما يحدث تحت السطح ويعرفه المقربين
منه وبالتالي سيدفعه الى الترشح او هل
سيحدث له عارض صحي مفاجئ خلال الفتره
القادمه يعني نتكلم من الان الى يمكن
منتصف او نهايه ثلاث 23 لو حدث عرض صحيح
مفاجاه هذه هي الاسباب التي تدفع بايه
لعدم الترشح ما عدا ذلك هو عازم على
الترشح وديمقراطيين يعني ليسو عازمين انا
اقصد يعني الجناح المعارض لترشح فائده ليس
عازما بقوه على مقاومه ومحاوله لانه هذا
قد يؤدي الى الانقسام الحزب وهم لا يرد
ذلك وعليكم استاذ احمد عن نقطه يعني حضرتك
تقول بانه قادما اذا صار شيء او اذا عرض
لي عار الصحي مفاجئ ولكن هفواته التي كنا
نتبعها طيله الفتره الماضيه لن نتحدث عن
السنه على فكره لانه السن همم لا يرتبط
يعني يمكن ان ترى انسان متقدم في السن
ولكن بذاكره ممتازه بطريقه اداء ممتازه
والعكس كذلك صحيح انسان في سن مبكر ويمكن
ان تكون له اعراض لا تناسب مثل هكذا منصب
فما يحدث لبيضن كيف يمكن توصيفه البعض
تحدث عن الزهايمر البعض الاخر تحدث عن همم
بعض الامراض النفسيه الاخرى فعمل نتحدث
الرئيس بايدن ااه ليس جديدا عليه موضوع
زله يعني الاخطاء الاخطاء اللفظيه وذلات
اللسان
يبررها يعني مؤيد وبانه اولا هو يعاني من
التاتاه كان في صغره يعني 23 شديده
واستطاع التغلب على هذا الحاجز ولكنه
مازال هناك يعني بعض العوارض التي تنتج عن
الموضوع هذا التدريبات التغلب على احيانا
تستنتسب ان الواحد يستخدم سليم معينه في
الكلام قد تؤدي الى بعض الاخطاء اضافه الى
انه اجرى عمليه في يعني في المخ قبل بضعه
سنوات وهذه تزيد من اثر هذا الامر هم
يقولون ان هذه ليست اشياء جديده وليست
اشياء مضحكه جدا من زمان وهو ناجح ناجح
سياسيا في قياده الحزمه رغم كل شيء ولكن
الاستاذ ايهاب نحن لما هم يقولون ذلك اكيد
والمتابعه تصريحاتهم ولكن لما نتابع
الارشيف نتابع بانه همم
يخطب في الكون بس وكان حتى مثال يدرس
للخطابه همم كان حتى همم يعني خطابته كانت
فيها شيء من ال- من المسرح همم كان يجسد
الامور الموضوع لا يتعلق فقط الموضوع حتى
يتعلق بالنسيان حتى نستذكر مع بعض همم في
مؤتمر صحفي كان يبحث عن واحده من اعضاء
الكونجرس كانت توفيت منذ فتره وكان يبحث
عنها ويقول اين هي بالضبط في استاذ ايهاب
هل هذه الشخصيه قادره ان تقود الحزب
وقاصره عن ترشح نفسها للرئاسيات تعتقد
طيب يعني لقينا في البدايه اقول ان باي
دين شخصيه سياسيه مؤثره وقويه ولها تاريخ
طويل في العمل السياسي الامريكي لا نستطيع
ان ينكر ذلك وفي نفس التوقيت له قدرات في
قياده الحزب الديمقراطي وهذه القدرات بكل
تاكيد تقل بمرور الوقت خاصه ان الرجل 8
يعني اصبح بشكل او باخر همم لديه غفوات
كثيره وسقطات كثيره تعبر تعبر عن ذهنيه
ليست
ربما صافيه او ليست على المستوى المطلوب
بقياده دوله كبيره كاد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع كامل الاحترام لشخص طبعا كل
تاكيد همم وداخل الحسبه ديمقراطي هناك
شخصيات كثيره ثياب زهور نجم خلال همم
الاشهر القليله القادمه من بينهم طبعا
نائبته كمالهارس وهي ما زالت صغيره في سن
اعتقد ربما اا تبلغ خمسه 57
ولا حتى تمكنت من ان تظهر بجانبه في
فعاليات كبرى نعم خاصه انه اوكل اليها ملف
من اهم الملفات وحتى الان هذا الملف اضاءه
الديمقراطيين فاشل في تماما هو ملف الهجره
وحمايه الحدود ماده حتى ان يستقيل رئيس
جهاز الهجره وحمايه الحدود الامريكي قبل
اسبوعين من منصبه اعتراضا على السياسات
التي ادت الى دخول خمسه ملايين مهاجر الى
الولايات المتحده بشكل غير شرعي خلال
عامين فقط وهو ما كان دائما ينجد به
الرئيس دونالد ترامب الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحده بيقول له الاضافه اللي
كمال هاريس هناك شخص وهو همم حاكم ولايه
كاليفورنيا
ويستطيع هذا الرجل بما لديه من زخم وقرب
من همم يعني الديمقراطيين الذين يمولوا
الحملات الرئاسيه بشكل كبير يستطيع ان
يخلق الزخم خلال الفتره القادمه كي يكون
احد المرشحين المحتلين عن الحزب
الديمقراطي لخوض في الانتخابات
بانه همم الاكيد
سيرشح نفسها للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
يعني هذا يقين لدي لسبب ان بعض اه بايدن
شخصيه قتاليه اللي هو لا يستسلم فانا
اعتقد هو سيرشح نفسه لكن هل هذا الترشيح
سيلقح ترحيبا داخل الحزب الديمقراطي لن
يلقب بالشكل الكبير الا اذا هذا الترشيح
تم مبكرا جدا واستقر ديمقراطيون بشكل كبير
على الرئيس لدفعه الى الامام كلهم بمن
فيهم جابر يوسف وكل الشخصيات الاخرى التي
من الممكن ان تترش
او ان يبرس في ظل غياب همم افسر اكثر
البعض يقول انا بعيد النجاح في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه همم
لان همم ترامب كان امامه ولان كان هناك
محاوله لاستبعاد ترامب فبرز بايدن وفاز
بهذه الانتخابات اذا ما تقدم الحزب
الجمهوري بمرشح قادر على ان تكون له قاعده
شعبيه كبيره هو محترمه وقادر ان همم يعني
همم يقدم نفسه حتى او همم ان يكون حاضر
حتى بقوه داخل حزب الجمهوري هل تعتقد بانه
لبيضن ستكون همم فرص للنجاح
ان يقنع قادر ان يقنع بحثت على الكلمه قدر
ان يقنع تفضل
نعم لا شك ان احد عوامل فوز سبايدر في 20
20 كانوا وجود ترامب ولكن يعني ما سيقول
لك مؤيد بعيد انه فاز في 20 22 يعني هذا
الحزب الله فوز رغم انه ترامب احتفظ بهدوء
لفتره طويله يعني كان كان غائبا قدر
المستطاع خلال الاشهر الاخيره من
الانتخابات وبالتالي لم يكن التصويت
بالضروره ضد ترامب بل كان لصالح المواضيع
او الشوز اللي طرحها يعني همم الحسبه
الديمقراطي بقياده همم لا شك انه كل كل
الحزبين الحزبين كبيره لديهم القدره على
الفوز تحت اي ظروف فبالتالي لا يمكن الجزم
سيفوز او انه يعني فوزه قريب من المضمون
ولكنه هو المرجح خصوصا انه ترامب سيظل
يعني غصه في حلق الجمه لفتره لا باس بها
اكثر هذه النقطه لما تقول فوزه مضمون همم
او ترشحه مضمون تتحدث عن ارادته هو شخصيه
او تتحدث عن اراده الحزب بان الحزب كذلك
يؤمن بان بيضا يجب ان يكون هو الشخص الذي
يرشحه الحزم في الانتخابات القادمه ويراهن
عليه
ما لم يتمكن من اقناع بايضا بعدم الترشح
لن يخرج احد من داخل الحزب لمواجهه بايضا
وبايدر في الترشح ما لم ينسحب ايضا من
نفسه فلن يترشح احد ضده همم يريد الترشح
وسيفعلها ما لم يتعرض لعرض صحي هذا
بالنسبه للترشح والفوز يعني بالفوز بترشيح
الحزب ما ما قلت انه ليس مضمونا هو الفوز
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه يعني في
الانتخابات العامه الانتخابات العامه
استحملت كل الاحتمالات وان كانت يعني
احتمال فوز فايت ان هو الان هو الاقرب
على كل سيبقى موضوعا للمتابعه ساكتفي معكم
بهذا القدر حتى الان على ان نناقش تطورات
هذا الموضوع لاحقا من واشنطن الخبير في
شان الامريكي والعلاقه الدوليه ايهاب عباس
ومن هيوستن احمد الحنطي البحث في شان
الاميركي شكرا لكم